a stark warning from Germany's Health
Minister he says there will be no swift
end to the corona virus pandemic as a
result Germany is introducing new
measures for dealing with the virus long
term including more testing and stocking
up on additional flu vaccines to prevent
a wave of double infections in the fall
the latest figures from the Hobart Kroc
Institute provided the clearest picture
yet as to how the epidemic has developed
in Germany the calculations show when
and how many people became infected and
when key steps were taken to slow the
virus spread the ban on public
gatherings took a while to make a
noticeable difference the closing of
schools brought infections down
considerably German health minister Yun
Spann says the number of registered
acute infections in Germany has been
falling for over two weeks and is
currently at 37,000 but regional
differences remain so the government
announced that testing will be stepped
up even further from nearly half a
million tests last week let's swing one
via vehicle half done emulation
will introduce more regular testing in
care homes including for asymptomatic
patients we're also changing some of the
rules for tests to get a better overview
of the epidemic and we're introducing
compulsory reporting of negative test
results lists for negative a tester get
design work on an anti covert 19 vaccine
in Germany has meanwhile taken a step
forward minds based company by on tech
says a first group of 12 participants
had received a trial vaccine on
Wednesday but with the progress of
infection still unpredictable across
Europe Germany's foreign ministry has
decided to extend his global travel ban
until mid-june foreign minister hai
Kumar said that Europe needed to find a
coordinated approach let's hear one over
the last four weeks we brought 240,000
tourists from all over the world back to
Germany we will not carry out such an
operation again this summer which is why
a lot will depend on how we get on with
fighting the pandemic here and another
trees and amoeba khemphone Burlinson in
under the lenin right I get protesters
and pressure groups meanwhile are urging
the German government to ease even more
of the current restrictions on Thursday
the state premiers of Germany 16 states
will reassess the situation with
Chancellor Angela Merkel let's get more
now from our political correspondent Tom
Sparrow tell us what can we expect then
from Chancellor Merkel's talks with
Germany's state premieres later today
Terry this will be mostly a discussion
on the measures that were already taken
a few weeks ago as a sort of interim
balance if you will where the regional
leaders entangle America will take stock
on what was decided and what progress
has been made there could be decisions
for example the reopening of museums or
the conditions that have to be met for
religious gatherings to take place or
also for example something particularly
interesting what will happen with German
football the Bundesliga but it is not
expected that there will be very big
announcements those big announcements if
there are tipping announcement would be
expected in the meeting that will takes
place next week so again this is mostly
a sort of interim balance of the
measures that were already taken a few
weeks ago okay a lot of focus on opening
schools of course if we could just bring
back up that graph we had in our report
it shows new infections in Germany
initially rising and only seemed to
start falling once this country schools
we're shut of course lots of other
things are happening at that time too
but it's been decided that the schools
will start to reopen next week Thomas is
that not a risky move from a public
health perspective it is a risky move
and in fact a group of leading German
biologists just this week published a
report in which they said that children
could be as infectious as adults and
they cautioned against an unlimited
reopening of schools in the present
situation so it does explain why the
situation of reopening schools is such a
complex and difficult one and it also
explains Terry why authorities decided
to give school some time to prepare in
order for children and be opposed to go
back to school with the necessary
health measures with the necessary
hygiene measures with the necessary
social distancing measures but it is a
very difficult and a very tricky
situation how exactly to have that
gradual reopening of schools let's talk
about the vaccine trial that's begun
here in Germany twelve people have now
received doses of a vaccine candidate
does this mean that development of a
viable vaccine could go faster than the
12 to 18 months we've been hearing about
German health experts have said that
this could certainly take that time and
in fact Germany is not the only country
that is having these clinical trials
we've seen that in other countries as
well although there are development
projects for ever seen in many different
parts around the world but health
experts have indeed indicated that it
could take that time it is not something
that is going to happen very quick
indeed Thomas thank you very much DW
political correspondent Thomas Peres
it's roundup of so the latest
developments in the pandemic South Korea
says it has recorded no new domestic
cases for the first time in two months
the Korea Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention reported four new cases
all of them imported Japan is expected
to extend its state of emergency by
about one month for the entire country
it's currently scheduled to expire on
May 6th
South Africa has seen its largest
single-day jump in cases with the total
surging past the 5,000 mark and the
Health Ministry in Guinea Bissau says
Prime Minister Nuno Gomes nubium has
tested positive for kovat 19 the West
African country has so far recorded 205
cases and one death